so i'm going to do a brief uh
introduction so next speaker is natasha
jack
who unfortunately couldn't come for
some uh covet reasons
for the anecdotes like last time uh it's
it's me who could not uh invited her but
it's me we could not attend because my
daughter got born
uh just the the very started before the
her talk so i hope like the the the next
time we we will manage to meet finally
so uh
natasha made her phd uh at mit media lab
with uh brazilian picard in affective
computing
and
pursue with a
position
a senior
research scientist position at google
brain and
simultaneously
visiting postdoctoral
fellow at bayer in berkeley and our talk
is about social reinforcement learning
there you go
let's hope it would work
yes
hi i'm natasha jakes and today i'm going
to be presenting about my work on social
reinforcement learning
so when i like to think about what
motivates my work i like to think about
trying to make an ai assistant that
could help us with a bunch of everyday
tasks so it could do things like be
physically in our environment with us in
our kitchen helping us prepare a meal it
could do complex tasks like helping us
manage our calendar and it could drive
us to work so if we think about an
assistant that could do all these things
what abilities are lacking in
state-of-the-art ai that we need to make
progress on before we can enable this
well um i think if it's going to drive
us to work it needs to be able to
coordinate with us in shared spaces um
for example on roads but if we look at
the state of the art in multi-agent
coordination for example in this darpa
robotics challenge uh-oh there seems to
be a few coordination problems here
and actually they just uh
lost that drone as a result of this
coordination failure so we still need to
make some progress on coordination
and uh
i think if we want this assistant to
work effectively we actually wanted to
be able to learn from natural
interactions with us so wouldn't it be
great if your roomba could understand
your natural language commands and it
could uh understand your gestures and
your social cues but if we look at the
state of the art in
learning from human interaction today we
still see a lot of systems that are
learning from manual button presses for
example people filling out these cards
saying how satisfied they are with
google's results
and finally if we want an assistant that
can do complex skills like uh helping us
prepare a recipe we actually need to
make fundamental progress in terms of
learning and generalization so in order
to do a recipe you need a complex
sequential decision making over a long
horizon and multiple complex subtasks
and if we want to deploy these types of
robots to everyone's homes we need
really effective generalization so
ideally we want an agent that we could
train in a simulated kitchen and deploy
it to everyone's kitchen in the world
but if we look at the state of the art
and generalization today
we see that you know even in atari if we
train in the entire environment on the
left and then just tweak the colors and
the paddle size the agent will utterly
fail to generalize to this new
environment so we need a lot of progress
in things like learning and
generalization
and i'd like to make the case to you
that actually social learning can help
address all of these desiderata so it
might be obvious that social learning
can help with social problems like
coordination or even learning from human
interaction but i'd like to argue that
it can actually help with fundamental
issues like learning and generalization
as well
and so what do i mean by social learning
basically i just mean learning from
other intelligent agents that are
present in your environment and this is
a very ubiquitous strategy in the human
and animal kingdom because it can be
very effective
so for even this little one-inch fish it
can use social learning to generalize
effectively to new environments by
looking at where other fish are
gathering to find a safe source of food
and in the uk there's this fun example
of birds that learn to open milktop
bottles not because each bird
independently discovered this behavior
but because they could learn by
observing other birds
and of course many authors have argued
that the key differentiator that humans
have versus other animals is actually
our social learning abilities and it's
those incredible social learning
abilities that have led to our
impressive cognitive cultural and
technological development
so social learning can accelerate
learning individual learning can be
unsafe error-prone and time-consuming
but social learning lets you stand on
the shoulders of giants
and so my
research works on social reinforcement
learning in two contexts one in
multi-agent interactions where you're
learning from other ai agents and two in
human ai interaction where you're
learning from humans and i'm going to
talk about both of these aspects of my
work today
and to give you a broader overview of my
work i've worked on
the more human ai side where i've worked
on detecting human social and emotional
cues
then learning from those cues and
interactions with humans
teaching multiple agents to coordinate
with each other
multi-agent social learning specifically
and uh setting up multi-agent systems
such that they give rise to the
emergence of complex behavior
and so for today's talk i'm going to
talk about those two aspects
and i'll start with this social learning
aspect first because i think it kind of
gives a lot of context what i mean when
i say social learning
so is social learning just imitation
learning i mean i said it helps you
stand on the shoulders of giants but so
does imitation learning if you want to
quickly acquire behavior from something
an expert already knows how to do you
could just use imitation learning so
imitation learning is just supervised
learning on a curated data set of expert
state action pairs
but the issue with imitation learning is
that you're given this data and you
basically copy it exactly so we know
that imitation learning performs poorly
if the data is going to come from
imperfect experts because you're
indiscriminately copying all of the
actions in the data set and so here in
this figure you see a comparison between
imitation learning methods and offline
rl methods which are able to
find a better policy on top of the
imitation data
and the other issue with imitation
learning is the resulting policies are
brittle and they don't generalize well
so if you go off of the support of the
state action data set that you had to
copy your policy doesn't know what to do
whereas reinforcement learning can
explore beyond that and potentially
improve and i'll show the brittleness of
imitation learning and some results that
i'm about to present
so when i'm talking about social
learning with multi-agent rl i'm talking
about something a little bit different
here i'm thinking of you're in a
naturalistic setting where there are
other agents present in the environment
but they're not necessarily motivated to
teach you so imagine real world settings
like the human world there are a bunch
of other agents running around but
they're just going about their business
they're not trying to actually teach you
any information or provide you a curated
data set of what you should do so this
is true of settings like autonomous
driving there are other cars on the road
and some of them are
really intelligent and might be doing
the right thing but some of them
actually might be bad drivers so you
don't want to indiscriminately copy
everyone
what you actually want to do is have a
social learning ability to determine who
is a good model that you should be
learning from and in what context
and so basically social learning is the
skill of learning how to acquire
information from other agents
and
i would argue that this skill actually
allows you to adapt effectively to new
environments so if you know how to
acquire information from other agents
and you're put in a new environment like
let's say you go to a new coffee shop
and you've never been there before and
you're not sure how you're supposed to
queue for your coffee do you order the
counter do you sit down um you can learn
that by just observing what the other
agents are doing what the other people
are doing at the coffee shop so the
skill of social learning actually helps
you generalize to a new environment that
has other agents in it because you can
watch the other agents to figure out
what you're supposed to do
and so that's what i'm going to try to
show to you today
so let's talk about this first project
which i did with a student named kamal
and deuce and he's great
the idea here was we wanted to study how
much vanilla model free rl agents
actually engage in social learning so we
put rl agents in a partially observed
multi-agent environment
with an expert that was constantly
demonstrating the correct highly
rewarding behavior in that environment
so the expert is constantly showing
exactly what actions you need to take to
uh score a high reward in this
environment but it was a sparse reward
difficult problem and we operationalized
the definition of checking if the agents
are engaging in social learning by
comparing the performance of agents that
were in that environment with the expert
to agents that trained alone since the
beginning
so this is what you see um the expert
performance is shown in black the agents
trained with the experts are the social
agents in purple
and the solitary agents are shown with
the pink dashed line and what you can
see is that there's no difference
between the social agents and the
solitary agents
um
and so this shows that basically vanilla
rl agents have no benefit of social
learning at all so they're much dumber
than this little one-inch fish we talked
about so in this work we just did a
simple fix to address this problem we
said in addition to our agent deciding
on its rl policy it's just going to have
an auxiliary prediction loss to predict
its own next observation
and what's interesting is that implicit
in being able to accurately predict the
next observation you have to predict
what the other agent is going to do and
because you need to predict where they
are in the frame
so this was enough that it forced the
representation of the agent to encode
something about what the expert was
doing
and what we saw is that this simple fix
actually allowed our agents to
successfully learn socially from the
experts so that's that green line you're
seeing here
um they've now just with this auxiliary
prediction loss
reached the performance of imitation
learning agents which were given direct
access to the state action pairs of
other agents whereas our agents don't
have that they're just in the
environment with the expert
and so this is kind of cool you can say
you can learn effectively from other
agents in your environment even if you
don't have access to their data
but you might say i might have access to
their data like in autonomous driving i
probably do have a data set of the state
action pairs of a bunch of drivers so
why is it worth it to do this social
learning approach rather than just doing
imitation learning
well let me show you this so
what we're seeing here is the
generalization performance of both
imitation learners rl agents and social
learners to a series of new environments
that they've never seen before
and so what you're seeing is in the new
environment this green line is
an expert that's been trained in that
new environment so in each new
environment there are experts running
around that know how to do the task
the original rl agents in orange
generalize poorly to the new
environments we know rl can be kind of
brittle in that way
um
so do the imitation learners they're
extremely brittle much more brittle than
rl
but the social learners are shown in
purple here so they actually perform
pretty well across all three
environments and why this is happening
is they basically learned a policy about
how to acquire information from other
agents that they can deploy in a new
environment to figure out what they're
supposed to be doing
so i think this is pretty interesting
there's also another um interesting
finding i just want to highlight that we
can show that
social learning enables the agents to
discover skills that they would never
have discovered if they trained alone
since the beginning
so what you're seeing here is the
performance of solo learners as the line
on the cross the bottom
um and then agents that were trained
with either only social learning or a
mix of solo and social episodes so in
the solo episodes the agent is alone and
the social episodes are with the experts
and what you see is that
as you uh use social learning basically
the agents start to discover a behavior
from learning with the experts that
they're never able to discover if they
train alone but if you continue using
only social learning then the agents
become dependent on the presence of the
experts and their performance in the
solo environment um decays
uh so it actually gets worse but if you
do this mix of solo and social training
we see that the uh agents trained in
that mix
preserve their performance in the solo
environment
using the information that they gain
from training with experts so
essentially they're acquiring a skill
from the experts which they are able to
maintain and deploy when they're alone
which is fine
but this method was a pretty simple way
of helping the agents to engage in
social learning so can we develop more
sophisticated methods for doing social
learning
and so this was a project i did with
another student named angelo spilos
who's a great also and um here we're
going to use successor features to help
with social learning so if you're not
familiar with success or features i'll
just give you a quick rundown as you
know in rl we're trying to you know
estimate our total expected future
reward um which we can parametrize as a
q value
um which is the reward expected from
being in a particular state and taking a
particular action
successor features decompose this into
two components a psi component and a w
component and so what psi is doing is
essentially s doing all the hard work
that we have to do in rl of estimating
what's going to happen in the future so
psi is going to estimate
over the course of an episode how much
of these state features phi we're going
to accumulate
so imagine we were in a grid world and
we just had to pick up different types
of fruits so apples versus bananas you
can imagine phi would say at a given
time set did i pick up an apple or a
banana or nothing right so it's just a
bit vector
psy would say over the course of an
entire episode how many apples and
bananas am i going to pick up following
my policy right
and then w
is just a preference vector so this
stays the same across every episode and
it just describes how to map those state
features to reward so if the agent
prefers bananas twice as much as apples
we can just take that 2 1 preference
vector and multiply it with our you know
psi and compute our q value which is our
total expected reward from what what's
going to happen in the future
so why is this important to do well the
nice thing about successor features is
it lets you adapt very quickly to new
preferences right so if at test time i
say look you learned to pick up twice as
many bananas as apples but now i want to
change your preferences to pick up twice
as many apples as bananas so i'm
changing w to one two
i can instantly compute
which action will lead to the highest
payoff under that new reward using my uh
existing sai so i can do a very quick
adaptation to new preferences so this
actually helps a lot with generalization
so that's nice
so what we wanted to do is apply the
same concept to learning from other
agents
so what we're going to do is we're going
to model ourselves the ego agent as well
as all of the other agents in our
driving environment all the other agents
that are present on the road
using the successor features approach so
every agent is going to have this
estimated sigh that's estimating what
state features is going to encounter
according to its policy and this w which
are essentially its preferences
so we can learn the ego agent's
successor features or successful
representation just with rl as normal
and for the other agents we can model
them with maximum entropy irl so
essentially we say the other agents are
soft optimal we observe the probability
of the actions that they're taking and
we assume that an
action is exponentially more probable if
it has a higher q value or if the
successor equation is higher
and so we can use this to infer the
successor representation of the other
agents
but what's cool about that is then we
can say look
i inferred the other agents preferences
but i actually don't care about their
preferences i only care about my own
preferences
so what i can do is
substitute my preferences for every
other agent's preferences
and then ask myself
using this generalized policy
improvement idea
could i get a higher reward if i just
acted like one of the other agents
according to my own preferences
so basically at each time step i say
look if i were to take the action i'm
going to take my preferences and combine
it with agent 2's psi and that's gonna
give me the recommended action that um i
agent two would take if it were
optimizing my preferences and if i
compute that that action has a higher
payoff than my own action
then i can selectively imitate the other
agents to the degree that i compute it
would pay off for my reward function
so that's pretty fun
but of course in order to get this to
work we have to choose a phi in a very
specific way
so you might remember if we look at this
equation for psi and phi
psi is policy specific so it's counting
up what's going to happen in the future
if i'm acting like a particular policy
like agent two
but
phi is actually policy agnostic right
it's just the features that are
happening at a single state
so what we did in this work is we say
look all of the agents can share the
same underlying feature representation
phi
and
that's going to allow us to swap our
preferences with other agents
preferences we can ensure that those are
compatible
and
we can build up every agent's side using
the same phi
and so we get a lot of data as we're
trying to model all the agents in the
environment we get a lot of data that
can help us learn that phi
and whenever we learn something about
one agent that actually improves our
modeling of the other agent through
improving this feature representation
phi
and we learn these
phi's and size using this inverse
temporal difference loss this basically
looks like a bellman error
but without rewards
and um we can also improve our phi with
rewards when we're acting as the ego
agent so as ourself the ego agent we can
interact with the environment and get
rewards we can use that to further
refine our fi so we basically get a lot
of signal about how to train this
feature representation you can think of
it extracting a sort of a universal
feature representation that's capable of
describing any agent's behavior it's
extracting all the features relevant to
describing any agent's behavior
and so to zoom out for a second from the
math and give you the higher picture
basically what we're doing here is
um we're creating this feedback loop
where the more you learn from others you
can selectively imitate their actions
and choose actions that will lead to a
higher payoff for you based on copying
other agents when they're relevant
and then the more you act in the
environment and gain experience with the
environment and observe rewards you can
further refine that shared feature
representation which improves your
modeling of others
so the more you interact the more you
model others the better model the better
you model others the more you can steal
their
their actions and and get better reward
and so what's nice about this is we
tested it in a variety of environments
so some autonomous driving environments
and a grid world environment and a more
visually high dimensional environment
called fruitbot
and what we see is pretty interesting
so in the case where all the other
agents are relevant to what your task is
so essentially all the other agents are
doing the exact same task as you then
the best thing you can do is imitation
learning
that's going to learn the fastest but
our method learns pretty quickly it
learns more quickly than rl methods
in the case where the other agents on
the road are doing something exactly
wrong like parking on the highway if you
imitate them you'll do catastrophically
poorly so you see imitation fails in
this case the rl methods still do well
and so does our method
but in the realistic case where you're
in a multi-agent environment where some
of the agents are doing something
relevant but many of the others are
doing something
irrelevant then our method outperforms
both imitation learning and rl um
because it gets the best of both worlds
and the nice thing is we get some side
benefits of this method so
as uh
as part of doing our method we're
implicitly modeling
uh what other agents actions are going
to be next so we're being able to
predict other agents actions and we see
that versus different imitation learning
methods
our method can more effectively predict
what the other agents are going to do on
a held out test set especially when the
other agent's task changes
and our method works as an effective
inverse rl method so we can infer the
reward function that other agents are
optimizing and then effectively optimize
it ourself
and finally our method improves
generalization so
as opposed to imitation learning where
it can take up to a hundred new episodes
to adapt to
successfully imitating an agent in a new
task our agent can adapt in one shot so
this is actually pretty cool because
let's say during training you've only
ever been asked to pick up bananas in
this you know fruit picking world
at test time but you've observed another
agent picking up apples
at test time our method is able to adapt
one shot to the apple picking task
because they've already observed a
policy that's good at picking apples and
they can just switch to it by adjusting
their preference vector w so we get a
little bit closer to this one-inch fish
in terms of generalization
so in conclusion social learning is a
powerful mechanism that can help rl
agents rapidly adapt to new environments
and learn complex behavior
all right so let's go to the last part
of the talk so in this part of the talk
i want to talk about learning from human
ai interaction or learning from
interactions with humans
so
i think i'll start with this obvious
example about why you might want to do
this so
this is a real interaction someone had
with their alexa they say alexa what's
the right way to walmart and alexa says
the right way to spell walmart is
w-a-l-blah blah blah so this is
obviously not what the user wanted and
i'm going to bet you that the next thing
that they say contains some hint that
they were frustrated whether it's in
their tone of voice or their facial
expression there's some clue there that
alexa could learn not to do this again
and yet the way we often train ai
systems is still focused on using these
types of manual button presses for the
human to indicate whether they were
satisfied with the results
but if we were able to learn from this
type of social feedback like facial
expressions tone of voice um we could
learn much more ubiquitously and
naturally so people are giving us these
signals for free anyway as they're
interacting with ai systems so if we
could just pick up on them we could
learn more effectively
and so this is the focus of a project
that we worked on on learning from
implicit human feedback and dialogue
so what we did was we created a system
where we could deploy dialogue models to
the internet and have them interact with
people live
and here's an example of an interaction
and what you see is that when the user
or when the bot says something um that
doesn't make sense like sorry to hear
the user says that doesn't make sense
and we can actually detect from the text
itself that this is a good clue that the
bot is doing something wrong so for
example we can detect a negative
sentiment from that from that text and
that can serve as a negative reward we
can use to train the bot not to do this
again
similarly when the conversation is going
well
the user sentiment is positive
indicating that the bot is doing a good
job
so we can use this type of implicit
signal in the text itself to try to
train the bot to have better
conversations
and so essentially what we did was as i
mentioned created this online platform
for collecting this data
and
we did this by first pre-training a
bunch of dialogue models we had to
scrape some new data sets in order to do
this
and we put these models online and as
you can see in the interface we include
a few different features so we included
an upvote down vote button so the user
could manually indicate
whether they thought the bot was doing a
good or a bad job with that specific
utterance and we also included what
sentiment we were detecting from the
user so we showed that back to them to
say what the bot was thinking of of the
sentence that the person just set
and our hypothesis is that trying to
train the bot based on these explicit
manual upvotes isn't going to scale as
effectively as training on this implicit
sentiment from the user because while
the upvotes are the ground truth
the user's just not going to want to
provide them very often in order to do
that they have to deviate from the
natural chat interface that they would
normally be using and go out of their
way to provide that signal whereas the
sentiment is something that we get in
every piece of text regardless
um but in order to
do this work we actually want to dig a
little bit deeper and go beyond just
sentiment were there other implicit cues
that we could use from the text to
determine whether the conversation was
going well
so we scraped the literature on both
dialogue models and human human
conversations to look at what kinds of
signals are indicative of an empathetic
and engaging conversations and we came
up with a bunch of different options and
we looked at the relationship between
these metrics and the up builds and
downloads that we received in our
initial data collection and so we did
treat the uploads and downloads as
ground truth and we actually found that
these signals related reliably to them
so essentially um
asking questions turned out to be
related to getting upvotes
we found this from the human human
conversation literature it's supposed to
be an important active listening skill
reducing repetition on the part of the
bot is very good because that was from
the dialogue model literature and it
proved to be true
and finally we found that
really engaging with the user is
important so eliciting positive
sentiment from the user had a strong
relationship with um
with good conversations and eliciting
laughter and finally just staying on
topic with the user by maximizing the
similarity between the bot sentence and
the user sentence both in terms of the
sentence embedding and word similarity
so these were the metrics that we stuck
with for how to train a good
conversation model
and so basically what we wanted to do is
use reinforcement learning to actually
learn to optimize these metrics
by putting our bots on the web and
having them interact with humans so
basically instead of your normal rl
paradigm where the agent is interacting
with a simulated environment in our
paradigm the agent is actually
interacting with a human a human is the
environment that's providing rewards
based on whether they enjoyed the
conversation
um
but wait did i just say i wanted to put
an agent online and have it interact
with humans on the internet to teach it
how to talk
i think we've seen how badly that can go
in the past so
we decided in the context of this
project that we actually needed to
carefully test any model that we trained
offline before deploying it back to
human so we can't have it learning
online from interacting with humans
about how to talk
and so what this necessitated is
actually to do
uh
fully offline learning which means that
our normal interaction or exploration
part of the rl loop is broken um so
instead of being able to explore to find
which actions lead to high payoff we
have to learn entirely offline so we're
in this off policy from static data
batch or offline rl setting this is a
very challenging setting because a lot
of rl algorithms are built such that um
they're optimistic in the face of
uncertainty and the exploration is
actually key to refining the estimates
that they learn
so
i'll give you a quick illustration of
why offline rl is hard so let's say
you're this little robot and you're
trying to learn to walk to this red flag
but you're only given the data in a
single batch of data and the probability
that your c a state in the batch is
shown in yellow here so basically
anything in this region that's white off
of this yellow support is not in the
batch data
so the issue with offline rl is that if
at any point your policy is initialized
or
learns that going into this region of
unexplored space is a good idea it has a
high estimate for this region of space
it has no way to refine that estimate
because it doesn't have any data from
that region of space and
actually that bad estimate will
propagate backwards
into all of the preceding states right
because we're trying to estimate our
total expected future reward and so if
we ever think this is valuable that
incorrect estimate is going to be
propagated into all the preceding
estimates so basically estimating
value in offline rl can be arbitrarily
bad
but we saw this with a very simple thing
we just said let's add a kl constraint
so that we say that as the
agent is learning its rl policy it
should actually minimize the kl
divergence between its policy and the
support of the batch data so basically
search within this region of highly
rewarding behaviors here in order to
find the optimal policy so to put that
in math basically we're just doing kl
control from a pre-trained prior model
of probability of a given s
and this can be
learned from the batch data
or in the case of language we actually
have a really good model of which
actions are acceptable given the state
because this is just our pre-trained
language model
and so what we do
is we say instead of just maximizing our
expected reward as we would normally do
in rl we're going to minimize the kl
divergence between our rl policy and
this pre-trained model or our language
model
and so
in when we're estimating the q value
this amounts to adding two simple terms
we simply um subtract the log
probability of our policy so this is
equivalent to doing entropy
regularization which is a good idea to
do in dialogue anyway and we add the
probability under the prior um and so
this just says you're going to get a
reward if you take actions that look
probable according to the language model
and we do a few other tricks which you
can check out in the paper if you're
interested
but let me first establish that this is
an effective offline rl method so this
idea of kale control from a model of
what's probable in the batch is actually
performing well across a bunch of open
ai gym environments and outperforming a
batch constraint q learning which was
the competing offline rl method at the
time
but let's see this in the context of
dialogue so what happens if you don't do
this and you just try to use offline rl
on dialogue data
what you see is that your model starts
saying things like where did you say to
me you want to talk to you about you
so it's basically using very unrealistic
sentences so it doesn't know what is a
realistic sentence once it's off of the
support of the batch data so it can
become increasingly unrealistic and it's
just trying to maximize the rewards we
gave it by for example exploiting asking
questions because that's one of the
simplest rewards that it's able to do
that we gave it
um
instead of actually doing something more
sophisticated
but what we see is that when you add
kale control the model says things like
hey i hope you have a great day and i
wish you the best
so
through this constraint it's now learned
to use more realistic language but in
order to optimize these rewards for
example eliciting positive sentiment
it's learned to be very cheerful polite
and supportive so we inadvertently came
up with a metric that trains the bot to
be canadian
but what we see is that when we deploy
these models to new humans at test signs
so they're now back on the internet and
they're interacting with a new set of
humans we see that our models are able
to elicit significantly higher human
reward from the humans so they're able
to elicit more positive sentiment and
more laughter than
any of the baseline methods including
the original language model
so we see that we're able to effectively
learn with rl using this technique
um if we compare how optimizing each of
the different reward functions in
isolation leads to um
affects the human evaluation basically
we have a human evaluation where they're
raiding the bots on the quality fluency
diversity etc we're also looking at the
votes the upvotes down votes that each
bot received and the amount of human
reward they elicited
what we see is that as we suspected
um optimizing for
eliciting positive sentiment or
displaying positive sentiment leads to
the highest quality and the highest
human reward so we're seeing that affect
is important to good conversations which
was nice because this is keeping my
advisor of the affective computing group
very happy
but in addition
as we suspected if you try to optimize
only for the manual up votes and down
votes you don't do very well so you
don't get a high conversation quality
and you don't elicit much human reward
so even though this is kind of the
ground truth signal of what
conversations or what utterances the
humans enjoy it's not sufficient to be
able to train a good model because it's
just too sparse so when we instead use
these types of implicit signals like
sentiment we can do much better
we also looked at human evaluation
comparing each of the different models
so the
baseline offline rl methods that we
compare to
and as we suspected um
both in terms of the quality the votes
and the human reward the kl control
methods are are significantly
outperforming the rl baselines
but there is a caveat to these results
in terms of the original language model
that we used as our pre-trained prior
the rl methods do significantly
outperform it in terms of eliciting
human rewards
but they're actually not that good
in terms of beating the small in terms
of the conversation quality
so the original language model the
humans actually rate a slightly higher
quality which is somewhat ambiguous so
that could mean that our reward
functions are not sufficient to really
measure what is a high quality
conversation but i think there's
something else going on here um
in addition we don't have that much data
from this small human study but i think
there's something more profound which is
that
that model was learning to optimize
these rewards by modifying the
probability of outputting each and every
word so you're basically learning how to
maximize things like user satisfaction
at the word by word level and that's
actually a very hard learning problem so
what we did in some follow-up work is we
instead tried to learn the rewards at
the sentence level so we had a
hierarchical sequence of sequence model
where there's a sentence level embedding
that conditions a word level decoder
and by using continuous control to
modify that sentence level embedding we
can actually optimize for all of these
same rewards that i just discussed at
that work at that sentence level
and we see that this actually resolves
that issue so now what you're seeing is
not only does our rl model outperform
the rl baselines like reinforce um and
vhrl but what we see is that um
it actually outperforms both a
transformer language model and our
original language model that we base
this on so both in terms of human uh
ratings of quality as well as the amount
of time people spent talking to the bot
which we're taking is another implicit
signal of whether they enjoyed it in
this work
um
a fun thing to do is to look at you know
how well these models can optimize for
these different rewards so if we look at
our transformer baseline this is a
transformer trained on a pretty small
data set so it doesn't always have the
best performance um but we see that our
rl model can do things like optimize for
eliciting sentiment which we've seen i'm
in a sun room a lot and it's a great
feeling
it can optimize for asking questions so
um what do you do for fun we've seen
this
it can minimize repetition which is
important to maintaining conversation
quality as we saw and it can do this
more effectively again at the sentence
level than the word level so in this
conversation you know the user says how
are you i'm a reservoir engineer cool i
am still in college today is my first
day of vacation it's nice
it can also optimize the semantic
similarities so staying on topic with
the user so in this conversation the
user mentions ed sheeran the bot says
what genre is it and then the bot asks
for any recommendations so it's staying
on topic with what the user is saying
and finally and i think most importantly
in this work we also discuss the idea of
minimizing the toxicity of the model so
whenever you're training these dialogue
models on large-scale internet data sets
we know that they can exhibit biases
they can be exhibit racist and sexist
language
so what we did was we trained a detector
a classifier that says is this language
toxic and then what we can do is use
that as a reward function for our rl
model to try to minimize that toxicity
level and we see that our model is able
to do this pretty effectively and we
have
some results of that in the paper i
think this is actually really important
to emphasize why you might want to do rl
on top of language models right there
might be some non-differentiable metrics
that are really important for you to
minimize like toxicity that rl gives you
the ability to do that so whatever
metric you can decide should be a
quality of your text you can use these
rl methods to optimize for that
all right so in conclusion this is the
first work to propose kale control from
a pre-trained prior as a way to handle
offline or batch rl but the key thing
here is that we're using reinforcement
learning to to improve based on human
feedback and we showed that learning
from implicit signals from a human like
sentiment scales better than learning
from manual button presses
and as i mentioned in the last slide and
the other thing to note is that rl
allows you to optimize for any arbitrary
metric you can code up so if you want to
do something like reduce toxicity this
can be a really useful tool
all right so in conclusion social
reinforcement learning can improve
coordination with other agents human ai
interaction as well as fundamental
issues like learning and generalization
so i'll stop here and take any questions
thank you
all right so um
yeah unfortunately we can't take
questions but uh we hope you enjoyed her
talk
and
um i was making a joke that like uh yeah
you know usually like when people say
actually it's not a question but more
comment at least you can do that if you
want
so
uh but well if you we can also save time
for the run table yeah i think natasha
talk brings up a lot of issues that will
definitely be